hey i'm carla lalli music i am here to
critique some trending food let's dig in
[Music]
uh i have so many problems with this i
don't quite know where to start cotton
candy is not a barrier
for anything and then things inside
thinking that you can roll inside of a
sponge sugar it's not gonna work it's a
great catchy name cool marketing and
practice
[Music]
i think ramen crusted grilled cheese
combines a lot of words that americans
love we love ramen we love crusted
crispy and then grilled cheese so it
just seems like a really great winning
combination i do think that this trend
may have been inspired by an italian
grilled cheese called mozzarella in karo
karoza
mozzarella and carrots
where a grilled cheese with mozzarella
is actually breaded and dipped in
breadcrumbs and then pan-fried so we get
that really crispy outside crunch and
the super oozy cheese pull
[Music]
so grated egg is actually a very classic
accompaniment to like a fancy caviar
service where you would have your little
finely diced shallots and chives and the
fluffy grated egg so i love the idea of
taking that like airy ethereal
like lovely kind of egg texture and
applying that to where you might feel
like a fried egg in the past so
i'm into it i think you just need to
make sure there's enough moisture
happening in the avocado toast that it
doesn't feel dry or under seasoned
i love a cheese shell also known as
frico and they work when the filling is
really delicate so if you have a cheese
shell and you drop down some like
floaty fluffy pieces of arugula and
maybe drizzle a little bit of vinegar
over it eat it in one bite you're
totally in business if you take a cheese
shell and try to put like a taco filling
in there and salsas and wet stuff and
greasy stuff like 100 you're just gonna
be holding in your hands taco hands
big feta pasta started a a run on feta
that the world had not seen we were out
of feta in like many different countries
and the reason is is this combination is
really tasty and delicious so you've got
like that salty feta you've got sweet
tomatoes you're putting the pasta you're
just putting in the oven it's kind of
genius and the other thing that works
with feta is that it's a cheese that
will soften and take on flavors but it's
not going to melt down to a puddle when
you take it out of the oven you have
actually distinct nice bites of cheese
so
this one i know a lot of people who made
this and said it was actually really
really good
[Music]
i feel like mini pancake cereal is what
made tiktok famous for being food tick
tock from the jump and it's such an
insane idea it's fun to watch somebody
else do it but the idea that you would
stand there first of all that you would
make all of those teeny tiny pancakes
and then just dump them in a bowl and
pour milk over them
if i was making teeny tiny one by one
minuscule little pancakes every single
one would have like a tweezer of
softened butter and just a dollop of
maple syrup and i would savor every
single one because my time is worth it
thanks for having me drew i can't wait
to come back for more food talk
[Music]